who acting homeland security secretary
Chad wolf joins us from Washington DC
now mr. secretary good morning thanks
for being with us
you heard Paula Reid say this order is
not legally binding federal funding is
no way in no way tied to these reforms
how will they be enforced I think that
that criticism falls fairly flat I think
the president's shown and has
demonstrated leadership on this
initiative it's a tough issue but it's
one that again through the executive
order there's a number of things in
there that pushes this issue forward and
as you indicated at the top of the year
segment the president said yesterday
he's willing to work with Congress Tim
Scott and others in the Senate and the
house to continue these reforms if
Congress wants to put additional
measures in there the president the
administration is certainly open to that
the order is being criticized as not
addressing racial bias in policing you
have said you don't believe there is
systemic racism but do you believe
there's a systemic problem in the police
- police departments in this country
with regard to race I think what the
executive order lays out is a cumber of
fundamental issues that the president is
pushing forward one is on best practices
making sure that use of force
de-escalation is it's thought about is
accredited by institutions that are that
are there we talk about that information
sharing making sure that as police
officers move from one jurisdiction or
one police station to another that if
there's something in their background
that that is addressed before they're
hired somewhere else and then that
relationship between law enforcement and
social workers as as police across the
country respond to incidents regarding
mental health issues homelessness drug
addiction making sure that they have the
right individuals partnered with them so
I think there's a number of things in
this executive order that really
addressed some of the issues that been
have been at play over the last several
weeks in several years and and we talked
about it the president talked about it
yesterday
other administration's really didn't
push the envelope here didn't address
some of these critical issues and again
we'll work with Congress we'll work with
others to again push this ball forward
but what I'm asking mr. secretary is I
mean statistics show that black people
are more likely to be shot than white
people by police officers
is there an attempt a broad attempt in
this administration to address the issue
a potential racial bias within police
departments absolutely again I think the
president's been talking about this for
some time I think what we have to
realize is understand is is look at the
law enforcement community as a whole and
by and far these individuals that put on
the badge every day in the in the
uniform every day are good people that
do the right thing that don't abuse
their power there is a small small
minority that do that
we need to address that president's
talked about that I've talked about that
I believe AG Barr has talked about that
so we are looking at that but this
notion that there's systemic racism in
our law enforcement community I dismiss
that I don't believe that's the case
that says that we have installed and
design a system that installs racist
beliefs throughout our law enforcement
community that's just not true but we
need to do is we need to hold those that
abuse their power we need to hold them
accountable and we need to address that
and we need to make sure that there are
consequences to that and I think that
sends the right signal so then how do
you address though what happened to
George Floyd have you addressed the
series of videos that we've seen over
the past couple of years and actually
beyond that mr. secretary
again I what I have said about the death
of George Floyd is absolutely tragic
should not have happened and again we
need to hold those that have abused
their power that abused the badge that
they wear we need to hold them
accountable but when we talk about
reforming law enforcement so if you want
to look at the law enforcement culture
you want to look at their practices you
want to make sure that you give them the
training that they need you need to give
them the oversight that they need and
the leadership that they need and that's
what the president's doing through the
CEO it ties some federal funding to that
we need to make sure that we give law
enforcement the resources to change
those practices in that culture
instead of talking about defunding law
enforcement agencies it's just the wrong
way to go
secretary will thank you very much for
being with us this morning